as HBO is The Last of Us the first
really good video game adaptation time
will tell but early reviews are
uniformly positive tension and the last
of us have gone hand in sweaty
controller holding hand since the
original video game Masterpiece was
released in 2013. the post-apocalyptic
tale of Joel and Ellie's fungus riddled
road trip is one of the greats and
earned the right to be in the same
conversation as The Walking Dead and Mad
Max as far as stories set at the end of
the world go that stress level has been
raised again in the past few weeks in
the lead-up to HBO's live-action
adaptation arriving on January 15th
handled by The Game's Creator Neil
druckman and Chernobyl Creator Craig
Mason fans have been waiting with great
anticipation to see just how Pedro
Pascal and Bella Ramsay have handled
playing two icons of not just video
games but one of the greatest survival
horror stories ever told now the Waze is
finally over critics have shuffled in
online like clickers with their final
verdicts on the all-new series ahead of
its release this Sunday has the
unthinkable finally happened has The
Last of Us been given the treatment it
deserves in its transition to live
action by the sounds of things that may
have even surpassed him as the show is
sitting at 100 on Rotten Tomatoes as of
the making of this video Empire gave it
a perfect score of 5 out of five
praising it for accomplishing where
others failed John Nugent wrote the
live-action The Last of Us is a superb
example of how to make an adaptation
work how to retain the elements of a
world while having the confidence to
explore bold new avenues to expand the
universe to make a thing that stands on
its own two feet in the game Ashley
Johnson and Troy Baker are the
performers beneath the pixels of Ellie
and Joel Bella Ramsay and Pedro Pascal
are a live-action iterations of the
young girl with a big secret and the
Father Figure Falls to protect her I'm
not family no
your cargo
admittedly Pascal playing The Reluctant
guardian of a youngster isn't anything
new for him given the fact that he's
been doing a tough world for some time
now as DIN jarin and the Mandalorian the
real success story however looks to be
coming from Ramsay whose role on the
last reversible and doubtedly demand
more of the young Star as the show
progresses Simon cardi of IGN wrote
Bella Ramsey is simply electrifying as
Ellie effortlessly shifting between
delicate vulnerability youthful
excitement and determined power she's a
true Revelation and deserves all the
credits in the world for making her mark
on a character whose previous
interpretation has been so firmly
ingrained in people's minds it turns out
though that while these might be winning
turns from the show's leads there's a
surprise in the supporting casts that
might steal the show from them minor
spoilers for episode 3 ahead as much as
Joel and Ellie will try to avoid
strangers and infected stragglers during
their Journey The Last of Us the game
does include some supporting stars who
are willing to help albeit reluctantly
one fine example is Bill the anti-social
alloy played on the show by Nick
Offerman who shares the scream with his
on-screen love frank played by Murray
Bartlett of the White Lotus according to
Daniel Feinberg of The Hollywood
Reporter episode 3 is mostly the
portrait of an unexpected and fully
heartbreaking relationship between
survivors played by Nick Offerman and
Murray Barlett so good and so
inextricably linked at the TV Academy
may need to set new president with a
shared guest acting nomination something
that's only briefly hinted at in the
game Bill and Frank's time together is
seemingly brought to the Forefront in
the show it does yield a nomination or
two come award season by the sounds of
things it wouldn't be the only one for
the last of us one of the best games
ever made might have just become one of
the best shows of 2023
[Music]